with a floater yeah but that's where the  size right there just over a smaller  maxi able to  get it quickly two feet in the paint and  then a nice little floater over the top  so we saw a little burst from  philadelphia the celtics have answered  five second difference shot clock the  game clock  maxi watched by white high screen embiid  pick and pop embiid  uh that is not allowed no  legal plan maybe at the y in the park  you don't think someone would call that  well they'll call it but you argue it  and you may be able to get away with it  if you his size at the park yeah that's  three consecutive philadelphia turnovers  celtics five seconds